[Musique]
dr barrette pour gagna bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors le royaume uni considère le
connard le coronavirus comme menace
grave et imminente
pourquoi une telle déclaration
aujourd'hui du ministère de la santé
avec des je pense que c'est un problème
global
c'est un problème qui va toucher la
plupart des pays du monde pour noir il
est temps que les nations du monde
entier collaborent afin de lutter contre
cette infection ensemble peut-être une
déclaration sur les propos du président
américain donald trump
il estime que le coronavirus va
disparaître en avril avec la chaleur
quelle est votre réaction à ces propos
les informations actuelles sur le
coronavirus sans besoin nous avons
l'impression que avec l'émergence de
températures plus chaudes deux journées
plus longues avec moins de promiscuité
il est possible que effectivement ce
sera la fin du tunnel
c'est un peut-être mais on peut
l'espérer en tout cas pour revenir aux
déclarations du ministère de la santé
est-ce que cela ne risque pas finalement
d'inquiéter voire d'affoler la
population outre-manche
je comprends tout à fait et mes
collègues dans le pays entier
travaillent très dur afin de mettre en
place
d'envoyer un message très simple et très
clair au public
c'est le suivant nous avons un problème
nous devons nous travailler de concert
le royaume uni à une infrastructure très
performante et les autres pays européens
également à bonfol a besoin de lumière
posture que l'afrique tienne man u pays
l'inde ou le pakistan le bangladesh où
elle et ça fera structures de santé ne
sont pas aussi bas par rapport à l'union
européenne
en tous les cas très concrètement
quelles sont les nouvelles mesures qui
vont être prises au royaume-uni
poursuivre notre politique de
confinement c'est à dire que nous
souhaitons s'assurer nous assurer que
toute personne qui s'est rendu dans un
pays où il ya eu une transmission des
infections avec secours navires us sera
mise en quarantaine et nous appliquerons
cette période de quarantaine de 14 jours
plus tôt qu'une quarantaine quarantaine
tout en donnant des conseils pour
maintenir la bonne santé moi même et mes
collègues diffuser ce message si vous
vous sentez mal alors il faut que vous
vous confirmez vous même et notamment si
vous avez été en contact avec quelqu'un
de vraiment de choix ou ati aux
alentours des pays asiatiques
une large alors même que ce virus
existait déjà il faut également appliqué
de bonnes mesures d'hygiène
c'est à dire se moucher avec des tissus
en papier se nettoyer les mains et se
laisser chez également c'est très
important
faut également que vous l'aviez les
mains avant de manger
alors pourquoi le royaume uni a dit
adopter une attitude beaucoup plus
sévères que les autres pays européens en
tout cas comme ici en france est-ce que
d'après vous les autres pays européens
devraient eux aussi adopté ce type de
mesure à l'effectif our minds à elle est
difficile est de conseiller les
gouvernements je ne suis qu'à un docteur
indépendante revient car universités je
ne pense pas que
notre approche est très complice vert
que les autres pays européens
je ne pense pas que nous allons beaucoup
plus loin c'est peut-être une question
de langage la façon dont nous avons
communiqué sur la situation nos
procédures de confinement que ce soit au
royaume uni ou à l'union européenne sont
très similaires
alors il ya eu ces cas de citoyens
britanniques en france à haute savoie
coronavirus est-ce que selon vous la
france prend suffisamment de mesures
ce que je sais de la france je le pense
souhaite-t-on retenir le corps navire se
maintenir hors de notre territoire non
confirmées pas la solution qu'il
durerait toujours et nous aurons bientôt
des cases sur notre territoire
et alors nous mêmes nous assurer que les
cas sporadiques sont confinés aussi
rapidement que possible les traités qui
lient la lune retraçons les mouvements
des malades et que diffuser les bonnes
informations c'est la meilleure mesure
de contrôler pour nous alors pour
conclure comment est ce que vous voyez
la situation évolue et à quel moment
pour vous on atteindra le pic du
coronavirus je ne pense pas que nous
avons atteint ce jour l'histoire la
diffusion du virus n'a commencé qu'à la
mi décembre et le taux de contamination
a augmenté à fin décembre elle me semble
qu'en février
malheureusement je pense que nous allons
voir de nouveaux cas et
de la contamination qui atteindra
d'autres régions du monde mais ce que
nous pouvons faire c'est le contenir le
contrôler autant que possible ce corps
d'un virus
cela permettra d'avoir des conséquences
graves sur la population que ce soit
dans l'union européenne et au royaume
uni
merci beaucoup docteur en khâgne à
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en maladies infectueuses à
l'université d'exeter